les habitants de vallery s'y attendait
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
désormais fait jean-baptiste lemoyne
entre gouvernements le sénateur maire de
leur commune rejoint le quai d'orsay
pour damien buralistes du village c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
ce quelqu'un qui est très polyvalent
c'est quelqu'un qui est à l'écouté
quelqu'un qui a une très grosse faculté
de travail et qui est très ouvert
d'esprit
donc effectivement je pense que dans un
gouvernement tel que celui ci
il a sa place c'est vrai qu'il va nous
manquer mais de toute façon je crois que
quoi qu'il arrive il n'aurait pas pu
conserver son mandat de sénateur et de
mère d'ici quelques jours la petite
commune du nord de l'yonne va donc
devoir changer de maire jean-baptiste
lemoyne de son côté conservera un siège
au conseil municipal les élus ne sont
pas inquiets les projets en cours se
poursuivront
on espère qu ils nous oublient pas en
tant que maire de valoriser sa petite
commune de 500 habitants qui lui a
permis de de progresser là où il est
il faut savoir quand même qu'il est
parti de vallery il nous a tellement dit
qu'il avait fait toute sa jeunesse sur
vallery que
faut pas qu'il oublie quoi de son côté
delphine grémy labine hommes de
jean-baptiste lemoyne au conseil
départemental ne doute pas des capacités
du nouveau secrétaire d'état et se
félicite de ces nominations
il est très heureux et je suis heureuse
pour lui je pense qu il attendait donc
il a pris le pari a très longtemps de
rejoindre macron c'est son choix que je
respecte il est récompensé aujourd'hui
de son engagement et son pari beaucoup
ont critiqué
je pense qu'il sera gardé un intérêt
pour notre circonscription et pour notre
canton et on va on va travailler
ensemble et julien dray une nouvelle
page s'ouvre pour jean-baptiste lemoyne
une chose est sûre les habitants de
vallery suivront avec grande attention
les premiers pas de leurs élus au quai
d'orsay